but we're thrilled to be opening our
50th shop here at White City Westfield
if the largest shopping center in Europe
now with the extension that's just being
opened tomorrow and so we're thrilled to
be a part of it but this shop it
represents the latest in all our
thinking about the modern department
store how much of the revenues in this
door are going to be derived from
actually selling goods as opposed to
services and experiences well we've got
a full 23 services in this shop so we
believe that shops of the future are
less about fulfillment and just
transactions and they're more about
service experience leisure time so
whether it is the spawn and the beauty
treatments whether it's the styling
studio whether it's the demonstration
kitchen just near where we are now
whether it's the expert book of all
partners that you can get to give you
lessons in the discovery room on your
new tech there's all sorts of great
stuff going on here that make this more
than just a shop a lot of what you've
got in this store is very very upmarket
it feels almost like you're competing
not necessarily with other traditional
retailers but with boutiques just to
some extent that's right but we we sell
a vast array of products across all
sorts of price points so we believe
we're excellent value for money but
we're trying to also create an
environment that means that you want to
spend a day out here and really
experience this shop and so the
environment needs to feel really
luxurious and indulgent I mean retailers
been talking for quite a long time about
offering services and experience in
their stores the execution has quite
often fallen short of expectations how
come you're convinced you'll get it
right here well one of the things that
makes John Lewis really different is the
ownership model of our business so
everybody who works in a journalist owns
this business and we first spent a lot
of money and resources training partners
to be able to deliver this new the new
skills required of retail today and
we're genuinely very excited about that
we've got a fantastic group of 500 new
partners here who will go the extra mile
for you and everyone has been trained by
people from the National Theatre what
was that all about
we think the theater of retail it has
never been more important but we really
want to have partners who engage
confidently with our customers to
provide them the expertise and the
inspiration that customers want from us
so theater training just enables
partners to build their self-confidence
their voice and body language skills and
the reaction to it has been fantastic
and you're also rolling out some new
brands here that haven't been seen in
this country before yeah well we're
particularly excited about Madewell
which is a first launched on UK soil for
four customers at John Lewis but
actually this is all about creating a
reason to come into a physical space a
reason to come to Tallis for the
exclusive brands that we have the
emerging brands that are never seen
anywhere else and of course the
development of our own brands which
provide something really targeted for
our customers yeah you're aiming for 50%
owned brand in your stores by what sort
of period of time it's clear to us that
there's more that we can do to make sure
that we're targeting what we sell for
our our customers and what they know and
love John Lewis for so whether that's
about the the quality or the style or
the fashion ability of what we sell
we're really excited about some of the
new ranges that we've launched here so
if you take over the last few years
we've we've launched and aura of denim
lifestyle brand or modern rarity a
luxury ready-to-wear collection we're
really excited about the way that that
has been received and the opportunity
that's provided by us creating more of
our own product is this a good time to
be opening a store like this on the
consumer outlook it's not great right
now consumer confidence is low and their
behavior is changing but we still
believe in physical space we think that
there's plenty of opportunity provided
by retailers who create unique product
brilliant services and a total solution
for our customers and that's what you'll
experience here I mean making any
assumptions on where disposable incomes
are going to go this year I'm actually
optimistic about the the coming year
there's no doubt that retailers have to
be at the very top of their game to
succeed in conditions like this but but
we're thrilled about our current
performance and in
what we expect to happen when we finally
open the doors tomorrow